كتاب هو الامير البديل اليوم في الاسواق
الامير هاري قرر القاء عائلته تحت الحافله
من ابجل بضعه ملايين من الدولارات هكذا
تصف الصحافه البريطانيه مذكرات الامير
هاريسبير والتي باتت متاحه في الاسواق
اعتبارا من اليوم ضجه كبيره واعترافات
ربما تكون الاخطار منذ قرر الامير هاري
وزوجته ميغان مركنه تنحي عن اداء
واجباتهما الملكيه داخل قصر باكينغهام
مشاعره هاري مكبوته تنفجر وتهز القصر
الملكي مجددا مع هذه الدعايه ينفجر طلب
العلم على الكتاب وتصدر قائمه الاكثر
مبيعا على الاطلاق على موقع امازون المزيد
في هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
انشاء وهاري لاسرار ومواقف ومشاعر افراد
عائلته عند وفاه والدته الاميره ديانا
يروي عطش اسئله ربما راودت الكثير من
الناس حول تفاصيل وفاه الاميره الراحله
لكنه اثار في الوقت نفسه فضولا اكبر
لمتابعه ردود فعل الناس والقصر حول ما
يفرقه هاري من مشاعره مثبته
[موسيقى]
فمن لا يذكر لقطات الامير هاري واخيه
ويليام بعد وفاه والدتهما ومشاعر التعاطف
مع الاميرين الصغيرين من قبل الملايين ممن
تابعوا جنازه الاميره ديانا تساءل الجميع
وقتها ماذا يدور في بال الاميرين لاول مره
يكشف الامير عن المشاعر ذلك اليوم خلف
الابتسامه ومصافحه الناس هاري يقول انهما
اجبر على كبت مشاعرهما مؤكدا انه لم يبكي
والدته سوى مره واحده يوم وفاتها جديده
عاوزين صور
[موسيقى]
الذي يطرح في الاسواق ب 16 لغه مختلفه
سبقته ايام من تسريبات كشفت تفاصيل غير
متوقعه اقلقت العديد في القصر وخارجه حيث
اعتبر تصريح هاري مثلا عن مشاركته في قتل
25 عنصر من حركه طالبان تصريحا غير مدروس
كما اعتبر تصريحه حول استخدام المواد
المخدره تصريحا غير لائق لامير فيما اعتبر
الكثيرون ان تصريحاته لا رجعه عنها فيما
يخص ترميم العلاقه مع عائلته
هاري وتصريحاتهما حديث الشارع هنا في
بريطانيا مقابلات التلفزيونيه لاذعه
وقاسيه على افراد العائله الملكيه تزامنا
مع اطلاق كتاب يتصدر لائحه اكثر الكتب
طلبا حول العالم ولكن مع افصاح هاري لكل
ما في قلبه هل يوجد المزيد هل ياخذ هاري
استراحه بعد اطلاق الكتاب وانتهاء التسويق
له لصباح العربيه من لندن عروب عبد الحق
[موسيقى]
منذ ايام خارج التسريبات من اسبانيا
لمقتطفات مذكرات الامير هاري ولحقت بها
ثلاث مقابلات تلفزيونيه اخرها لقائه
ببرنامج جود مورنينج امريكا نستعرض اهم ما
جاء فيه اعترف هاري ان دوره وترتيبه في
بدايه العرش ربما هو سبب التنافس الغريب
باينه شقيقه الامير وليام كما يعتقد ان
شقيقه يشعر بالغير منه لانه لا يملك
الحريه التي يملكها هو يقول هاري انا
الصحافه كانت لها دور اساسي في الوقيعه
بين اسرته واسرته شقيقه وعامل على تحريف
ضد بعضهما البعض يقول انه لم يخطط هو او
زوجته لتركه منصبه الملكيه وانما اعتقد
انه وينصر هي المكان الذي سيقضي فيه بقيه
حياتهم لكن بالطبع تبدو العوده غير مرشح
الان
يشعر الامير هاري بالراحه بعد صدور
مذكراته يقول انها الطريق الوحيد لصنع
السلام وايضا يعمل ان يساعد على حمايه
ابنائه والاجيال الاصغر من افراد العائله
الملكه هل يعتقد ان النظام الملكي
البريطاني يجب ان يستمر وان هناك مكان له
في القرن الحادي والعشرين بشرط ان يكون
اكثر عصريه واقل انحيازا